[Music]
is that better yeah this is a talk that
I put together called top to down left
to right and it's a little bit about
Python so we're at PI data Warsaw it's
February
sorry Friday October 20th 2017 my name
is James Powell if you like this talk
you can follow me on twitter i'm dont
use this code on twitter i'm also don't
use this code on github in a lot of
other places i'm going to sit down for
the rest of this talk there's a lot of
typing involved this is a by the way
fair warning this is a novice talk and
this is a pure python talk so if you
know everything there is to know about
python this won't be very interesting to
you if you don't really care about
python like you're an art programmer
this really won't matter to the revenue
our programmers in here who are just
watching these talks out of pure spite
okay good this is part of a series of
talks that i've wanted to give about
what is it that the audience doesn't
know that they don't know about python
so a couple of things that even people
have been using python for a while might
be a little bit surprised about what i
want to do is i want to start you off
with a couple of questions then i'll
give you about three minutes of theory
that will explain all of the answers to
all the questions then we'll go through
all the answers as I go through the
questions I'm gonna need your immediate
feedback to get a sense for what is it
that you know and what is it that you
don't know so let's launch into it
really quickly I have two scripts top
and the bottom pane from math import log
I'll import a log of E in the bottom
import math math log math dot e what's
the difference between these two just
shout it out if you have any idea what's
the difference we don't we don't have
much time so you got to shout really
loudly really energetically one shorter
ones maybe a clearer one uses the
namespace is anyone else see
any difference between the two of these
nope okay let's move on this is a very
simple exercise I want you to shout out
valid if what I show on the screen is
valid Python code invalid if what I show
on the screen is invalid Python code and
if you hear somebody say the wrong
answer shout out wrong
just so I know that there's some
disagreement Python 3 this entire talk
is in Python 3 7 just because yeah
whatever right valid or invalid valid or
invalid valid or invalid wrong that
one's valid valid or invalid valid or
invalid everyone thinks it's valid
anyone here any wrong answers be sure to
shout out wrong so I know there's
disagreement let's do this next one here
valid or invalid invalid valid
mmm somebody has a right or wrong answer
how about this last one here who thinks
it's valid who thinks it's invalid who
thinks it's valid but useless that's the
right answer
let's also cover a couple of let's make
sure that you have a little bit of
background information so I have X I
have Y there 2 lists is X equal to Y
true or false X is equal to Y true they
have the same contents X is y true or
false false they are different objects
very good so if I append for to X does
it show up in Y no they're different
objects if I pen for two X it will of
course not show up in Y similarly if I
look at the IDs of x and y are they the
same ID or different IDs different very
good you guys are real smart let's take
a look at a very similar problem x and y
are they equal to each other
are they the same object very good so if
I pen for 2x does it show up in Y very
good what about their IDs they're the
same okay very good so you'll you won't
have too much difficulty with the rest
now let's say I have code that looks
like this at the bottom is a script that
imports the module at the top what gets
printed does called F get printed when I
run the script below no does defined F
get printed when I run the script below
what if I add this code does define G
get printed who says yes we got to shoot
from the hip we don't have a lot of time
to think in this talk so who says no who
says only defined F gets printed who
thinks that when I add in these two
lines it's not a lot of code here and I
add in these two lines the output of
script py changes who thinks it remains
the same nobody thinks it changes a
couple people think it's changed good a
couple of you have used flask or other
tools that have module reloading you
ever wonder why it is that when you
change something on disk you have to
shut down your Python interpreter and
start it back up or even restart your
jupiter kernel just to see those changes
why can't python be smarter why can't
python realize the file changed on disk
just reload everything let's take a look
at an example relating to that I have
Class A and Class B I have a script
below from module import a create an
instance of that is a an instance of the
class a got a shout it out
yes you can shout out an English polish
I'll take any language is B an instance
of the class B yes no yes of course it
is import Lib has a tool called reload
that allows you to reload modules is a
still an instance of a after I reload
this module
is be still an instance of be how about
if I write the code like this the answer
might surprise you let's take a look at
the last two examples a remains an
instance of a but B is no longer an
instance of B and then in the last
snippet of code there are neither
instances of the class themselves so
we'll see we'll go over a little bit of
theory to figure out why it is that the
answers to this are true/false for this
is false and false it might surprise you
okay
let's imagine that we're writing a
little bit of code maybe we're the best
Python programmer in our company and
we're at that company in order to show
people how to really write proper Python
code so we write a class and we need to
add a little bit of data to that class
maybe a little an attribute called B
except B for some reason or other can
never be negative
so if somebody tries to set B to a
negative number we need to provide some
error as quickly as possible you have a
co-worker who's a Java programmer and
tells you well that's a setter and a
getter what do you tell that co-worker
it's not very pythonic because what do
we have in Python that allows us to
avoid this pattern property very good so
you say write something like this use a
property and it'll intercept the set
attribute and the get attribute and
it'll just work you don't have to write
setters and getters and when your main
code looks like this it'll just work and
if I accidentally try and set this to a
negative number this line here will
raise an error telling me the value must
be positive everybody's in agreement
that's how you write proper Python code
let's say we have a module and that
module has a constant in it called a and
we have some script that alters that
constant maybe sets it to one what if
that constant can never be negative we
have to write a getter and a setter
don't we can we get around this mmm-hmm
so you see there's a break in this
pattern for a normal Python object we'd
use a property to get around having to
write getters and setters but you must
have seen this pattern on modules before
where people again have to write boring
getters and setters to intercept changes
to the module itself maybe there's a
better way let's look at another problem
and I think this is the second-to-last
problem we'll look at what gets printed
when I run the highlighted lines it's a
list what are the contents of that list
zero very good what if I add in this
next line here does it print the same
thing does it print something different
zero one very good some people have
heard of this problem
it's Kaufmann called mutable default
arguments what happens when the third
line gets printed
zero one two mmm that's kind of curious
this is a problem called mutable default
arguments when a default argument is
mutable some of the behavior might be
not be what you expect which is why if
you go under Stack Overflow and you look
up this problem you'll see somebody
propose an answer that looks like this
set X equal to none and then inside the
function check is X none and set it to
the default value if X is none here what
gets printed with the first line zero
what gets printed when I look at all
three lines zero zero zero probably what
I expected let's take the original code
up here and let's just nest it in one
more layer of a function what gets
printed when I run this is it 0 0 0 or
is it zero zero one zero one two
some people say zero zero zero does
anyone say zero zero one zero one two
let's take a look okay zero zero zero
hmm that seemed to fix that seems to be
another way we could fix this problem
how about here that kind of looks like a
decorator if I look at this this kind of
looks like what I do for a decorator so
if I create a decorator that looks like
that and I run the code in this fashion
what gets printed zero zero zero or zero
zero
one zero one two zero one okay very good
that's exactly what's gets printed what
happens if I stick this into a class
does that change the output which are
the two outputs do I get I don't know
all zeros or zero zero zero zero zero or
zero zero one zero one two
did I avoid my mutable default arguments
or not I did not avoid this problem what
happens if I just make that a normal
instance method does that have any
effect whatsoever mm-hmm each time so do
I get 0 0 0 or 0 0 1 0 1 2 0 0 0 0 1 0 1
2 mmm something's kind of funny here
let's look at the last problem that
we're gonna solve some of you know that
there is a built-in function called
locals and it gives you all the local
variables that you have in scope so
there's not much in this in the script
that runs you can see there's a bunch of
default variables name file package
annotations built-ins you might know
there's also a variable called Global's
in the case of a script like this the
Global's and the locals are the same
thing you can see from this line here
the locals is the same as the Global's
so that just gives me all my local and
all my global variables so if I say
here's my old locals I define X will
that show up if I look at the difference
between my locals after the definition
and before the definition will I see
anything new I should I defined a
variable well interestingly enough I
don't see anything new why might that be
well it's the case that this locals is
not a copy of all the local variables
but the actual current dictionary of all
the local variables so I might need to
make a copy just to see that change here
I capture what are my local variables
before make a copy of all those names
and then I'll print out the difference
and I can see oh this Y variable got got
created pretty pretty simple what does
this print
anybody else there's only there's homie
there's only a couple options that it
doesn't print anything or a prints 10 so
who thinks it doesn't print anything who
thinks it doesn't print 10 how many are
programmers here are like I have no clue
what's going on okay that prints 10
pretty easy
what is this print hopefully more than
one person can answer what this prints
what is this print 10 very good
what is this print good the confidence
level is rising what does this print
name error mmm
wrong answer wrong answer what does this
print 10 or 100 prints 10 had no effect
whatsoever that's kind of weird so maybe
it's a global what does this print does
this work it works and it prints 100
wait a moment something's really weird
python must be incredibly complicated
for all these different behaviors to
show up like this what does this print
and give you 2 to 3 choices
10 1 and 100 this is your basic closure
which of these three does it prints 10 1
or 100 100 anyone think of prints 1
anyone think of prints 10 prints 10
what does this print what error very
good it doesn't print 11a prints unbound
local error hmm that's kind of weird
finally and this is the last question I
have we have a bunch of statements in
the Python grammar while for with deaf
class two of these statements two of the
things that would show up in yellow on
my screen have no corresponding
executable code does anyone know what
they are actually yeah three of them so
including pass
so what else other than pass okay we'll
talk about that okay
so let's talk about the theory it's very
little theory behind this the reason I
like this talk and the reason I like
this topic is I showed you an enormous
amount of behavior what you couldn't
immediately guess the answer to and it
seemed like the model for how Python
worked must be very complicated it
seemed like all the operation of the
Python interpreter it's like a flash
back to when you were writing C++
there's no way that you could understand
how the Python interpreter worked but
you're wrong
the Python interpreter has an incredibly
simple execution model and I'm going to
give you about five minutes of theory to
explain how that execution model works
and then the answer to every one of
those questions will be clear as day in
order to do that I need to introduce
something there is a function in a
module in the standard library called
dis let's see what it does it
disassembles classes methods functions
generators or code okay so it shows me
what the byte code that runs in a see
Python interpreter for a given piece of
code so let me try and disassemble Len
oh I can't disassemble n so I can only
disassemble Python functions it can only
give me bytecode for things that are
written in Python it can't give me
bytecode for functions written in C like
the built-in function Len so let me try
and disassemble this function here well
that's interesting so there's a little
bit of data on my screen this three here
is the line number for the corresponding
bytecode it's printing out so line one
two three so this is the bytecode for
pass well you know that a function that
has no body
just returns none so what does it do it
loads the constant none and it returns
that value you can kind of see what it
does
loads of value and returns it the number
in this column over here is the offset
for the bike code so you can say that
load constitu bytes long you can't tell
me how long return value is but it's I
think only one or two bytes long this
value here is the actual OP is the
actual argument for that opcode and in
parentheses is the interpretation of
that so this load Const had an argument
zero which you can interpret as the
constant value none we'll see what that
means in a second let's disassemble this
function and see what it looks like well
it load fast so I don't know what fast
means but I know what load means it
loads the variable X it loads the
variable Y it does a binary ad well yeah
it doesn't add two things together and
it returns that value ok pretty simple
look bytecode actually is quite easy for
me to read let's take a look at
disassembling a class wait a second it
doesn't print anything at all it's kind
of weird let's wrap this in a function
and then try and disassemble it okay hey
I got something here so let's see what
it did it load build class I wonder what
that is
it loaded a constant value and that
constant value was a code object sitting
at some port in memory named a in some
file standard in it loaded a constant
the name a it called this thing called
make function it load another constant
it did a bytecode call call function it
stored that to the variable a it loaded
nun and a return it because this
function returns none so that's
interesting let's do the same thing with
the function let's see what happens here
I loaded some constants some code object
I loaded some constant which is just a
string with the name F in it I did this
thing called make function I stored it
to the variable F and I didn't return
anything okay let's take a module that
looks like this
it just has a function that was defined
in a class that was defined and let's
try and disassemble that function or
sorry disassemble that module well you
can see it when it try to disassemble
each of the constituent parts so nothing
too different than what I saw before
finally let's take a closer look at what
happens when I define a function I load
some constant I call this bytecode make
function and I store the result to the
variable F let's see what happens when I
define a class I do a couple of extra
steps but I still have some code object
somewhere I still have some store I
still have some call function somewhere
and I store the result to a what you can
see from this is when the Python
interpreter comes across a statement def
or a statement class this is an actually
executable code in a language like Java
or C or C++ class and function
definitions do not exist at run time
they get turned into just a bag of bits
and a compiler and C so the C compiler
will turn a function definition to a bag
of bits and maybe if you have debugging
options either on you can actually
figure out what that function is but
otherwise there's no runtime course
there's no corresponding runtime
execution of the definition of a
function but Python is different when
you see a function definition of a class
definition Python actually does
executable runtime steps to define it so
if we go back to the very first question
about what was valid and what is
involved I can define a class in 1/4 it
just defines the class over and over and
over because each of those def
statements is just some code that runs I
can define a class in a for loop it just
defines the same class over and over and
over and stores it back to the same
variable name it works but it's pretty
useless let's take action let's take a
look at this a little bit closer and
let's look at disassembling a couple of
things here I have a global variable
let's disassemble a function that uses
this global variable I see this load
global of X here okay kind of makes
sense the global variable so I should
have a load global it's not too fancy
let's let's do the same thing with the
local variable I have load fast so I
guess fast must mean local variable
that's kind of interesting let's see
what happens if it has a default
argument no change whatsoever so I again
see a load fast
so if it's a D if it's a local variable
with the default argument or not they
both turn into load fast let's see what
happens if I do this kind of closure
structure and I have the X on the inner
function refer to an X defined in some
outer function
I see low D ref so I guess D ref must
mean closure and let's see what happens
if I have a constant value
well load Const okay so I know there's
different types of loads global local
constant and closure or D right let's
take a look at a function that takes two
variables x and y what are the types of
x and y anything what does a bytecode
get generated from this binary ad does
Python know if these are two integers or
two strings or two objects does Python
know if these things can even be added
nope it defers all of that to runtime so
Python just sees some name X referring
to some object some name Y referring to
some object and it waits until this line
is executed to try to binary add them
and do something with that and if it
works it works if it doesn't work it
fails but you have no static knowledge
about whether that'll work or not
similarly if I call X is o or a function
let's take a look at the bytecode turns
into call function so that's why that
call function was it said you had a
function and you just invoke that
function does Python know if that's a
function or a class or a type or a
module or an object or something that
can't even be called nope Python just
waits until you try to do something with
it and it gives you an error if that
operation isn't supported let's say I do
an attribute look up there's Python no
let's take a look at the disassembly for
this you can see a load adder so I'm
trying to load an attribute does Python
know if the attribute a exists on the
object X does Python even know what X is
this Python know if X has any attributes
that I could grab nope it just waits
until runtime and tries it and as we
start to disassemble more and more
things we'll see this pattern recur
Python is a language that defers a lot
of decision-making to the runtime it has
a very small almost useless compile time
but there is a compile time and we'll
see in just one second what happens at
compile time
fundamentally Python runs code from top
to bottom left to right classes and
function definitions are just executable
code when it sees a function definition
it grabs all the stuff under that
function definition turns that into
bytecode and it every time that function
is defined turns that bytecode raps it
with a function name and creates a new
function of that type
same thing with classes that's why I can
define classes in a loop I can define
functions in a loop also a lot of the
core syntax of Python is as simple as
just doing load attribute get attribute
or binary or binary operations and in
that core syntax Python has no idea
until that line is run that the object
of its operating on is a class versus a
type versus whatever in this case notice
python does not even know X could be a
module if I change this to math dot a
Python does a load a tour just as though
were an object so what we can see is
that in that very first example with the
difference between the imports in the
second example when I did math log and
math dot e I'm just doing an attribute
lookup on some object and there's
meaning to when you do an attribute
lookup on some object let's take a look
at the last piece of theory that we need
to talk about I'll show you how python
actually runs code when you say import
module Python goes and it finds module
dot P Y or it finds a folder that
contains in a knit top py but eventually
it finds some dot py file and it reads
it in so it runs code that looks
something whoops
it runs code that looks something like
this and you can see this is the source
code of my module my module is just like
before it has an F and an a just reads
it in this is just a string
then it parses it so let's take a look
at what happens in the parse step I get
an ast so it just turns that source-code
tokenize as it turns it into an ast and
that AST has a body and you can see in
the body of this there's a function
definition there class definition let's
look at the function definition let's
look at the body of that function
definition it's got a return notice this
thing all I did was a returned one thing
let's look at the value that it returns
it's a binary operation let's look at
the left-hand side of that binary
operation it's a name it's a name X
let's look at the right-hand side it's
the name Y pretty simple this is just an
AST that encodes this same information
subject to checking the syntax is
correct and putting it into a structure
that can then be passed to the next step
which is the compiler Python compiler
takes this ast and it creates a code
object let's see what that looks like
just some code object here and let's see
what the code object contains well it
contains the actual byte code itself and
so you can see if I disassemble you can
see there's 24 plus order however the
size of return value in this code object
that's about 24 bytes here the code
object also contains some other other
interesting information the code code
name the name of the function itself the
names of any local variables the number
of local variables and some other
information as well some flags and so on
after it constructs the code object it
executes that code object it needs to
evaluate it and it creates a namespace
which is basically just a dictionary and
it just executes that code in the
namespace so let's look at the namespace
after executing my module well let's
look at its keys and it just contains
the function I defined F and the class
started to find a
now you know a namespace by itself isn't
very useful so we need to construct a
module and a Python module is just some
arbitrary Python object that has a name
has some lookup mechanism and has the
ability to look up the contents inside
so I simulated that by just updating the
dictionary of this object with with the
contents of the module so let's run that
and take a look so here I have my module
and if I do module dot a or module F I
get the contents of that module and then
finally somebody tries to use that
module so you might write something like
f equals module F we'll call that
binding and then you might call the
function f and if you remember the
function f just adds two things together
okay so that leads us to something very
interesting the import statement in
Python does not execute code the import
statement in Python brings a name into
scope when you say from module import F
that's the same thing as saying give me
access to the module in this case named
module and say F equals module F it
binds F when you say import module there
is no execution of code it brings the
name module into scope by doing
something that looks like this go to
system modules look up the module that I
want say module equals that maybe I'll
give it a slightly different name so
that this might be a little bit clearer
okay the execution of code only happens
as a side effect of when Python cannot
find the module in system modules let's
go back and let's answer every question
and think about this in very simplistic
terms everything operates top-down left
to right before we do that I want to
show you two small things this is the
Python compiler itself in the Python
compiler there is a function called
compiler named up when python code is
compiled the python compiler determines
where the variables come from so it can
emit either a load fast load global load
DRF or other load operation
it determines that by looking at the
static source text and figuring out
where was X defined and it knows X is
defined by either a statement that says
x equals class X for X in something with
something as X except something as as X
and so on there's only a finite number I
think 7 or 8 ways that a variable can
come into scope Python can statically
determine all of those and then
determine is this a local variable a
global variable a closure variable and
emit bytecode when you see a load fast
variable what it does is it loads loads
it fast it loads this variable from a
tuple that's stored
attached to a frame when it loads a
constant variable it pulls that from a
tuple of all the constant variables that
are collected at parse time when it
loads a DRF it goes and finds the
closure and then pulls it from the
closure so let's go back and answer all
of our questions there is a meaningful
difference between the two of these but
it is very subtle in the top you bind
the value of log and E early which means
if some Joker went in and did this on
line 7 you'd see the same result that
you saw in line 2 because you captured
the value of log and the value of E as
of line 1 and no subsequent changes to
that module will take effect here if
some Joker tries to do the same thing
line 7 does an attribute lookup just
like any other object looks up the
current value of log looks up the
current value of E and your Joker will
have his day this is why when you're
told to append your path in Python this
works this operates on the actual sistah
and it actually fixes your system path
this does not work what you accidentally
did was you bound the value of path
early then in your local scope you just
created a new shadowed version of the
system path this works because even
though you bound the value of path early
you perform the mutating operation on
the original path so this just works and
this works because you're looking up
sorry this should be sistah path you're
looking up the current version of path
and then setting the current version of
path that's why we see this difference
let's look at
the module when this module is imported
for the very first time and by the way
you may not be able to in a very large
system deterministically do you may not
be able to casually determine when a
module is first imported in a very large
system especially if your code is over
here and some bootstrap code or some
initialization code is over here your
module could have been imported at any
time in the process and it turns out
that your sister your there are certain
configuration options that can load
modules your site flags or your site
options can in some cases load a bunch
of modules that you might not even
realize are being loaded so you might
not actually know when a module is
imported so you might not actually know
when a module is executed in the script
below that module is only ever executed
once that is executed from top to bottom
left to right the very first time this
module is executed all three of those
defined statements are printed out to
the screen doesn't matter if you import
F from the module or G from the module
or H from the module some people when
they look at this they say well if I
import just log and E from math I use
less memory because I don't pull in the
other stuff nope Python always runs
modules in their entirety from top to
bottom
why because you could always at the
bottom of the module have a for loop
that defines some function many times
Python has no way to determine
statically where a function or where a
class is defined it could be defined by
some arbitrary arbitrarily complex
executable code and as a consequence the
only option that Python interpreter ever
has is to always run modules from top to
bottom left to right every single time
they get executed however as an
optimization we only execute it the very
first time it's imported this is why you
can't execute or load only certain
portions of modules you always grab the
whole module at the same time this is
also why in this case you had different
answers here the first two are obvious
but here we reloaded the module notice
that the a here is the a that I early
bound on line 3 so the lower case
a the a instance is still an instance of
the class that was early bound on line
three but on line 70 I look up the
current version of B in the current
reloaded module which will have been re
executed and it is no longer the
original be that constructed the
instance be on line 17 and on line 19 I
pull out the current version of a and B
from that module and the original a
instance and B instance are completely
different than what then we're
constructed by types completely
different than the types that sit in
that module right now this is why
arbitrary code reloading does not work
in Python you'll suddenly run into all
sorts of very weird errors where things
are no longer instances of things you
expect and it only works in very limited
domains where you can patch all of the
objects in your system to whatever the
new versions that were loaded by the
module are that's why the hot code
reloading in a tool like flask or Django
can sometimes break in very strange ways
if it's hot code we loader doesn't know
how to patch old objects to the new
definitions let's take a look at this
well here's what I know when I do
actually let's take a look at our module
when I do module a that's just a load
attribute right and so a module is just
an object that I can't easily construct
but the answer to this is quite easy
let's make B a property and say B dot
setter and then in my module I'll say if
my name is not main if i'm importing
this thing as a module what i'll do is
i'll go into system modules and i'll
grab myself i'll grab the thing that i
was supposed to be I'll grab the type of
it I'll grab the contents of it I'll
grab all of the contents that happen to
be properties and I'll create a new
class with all of the properties I'll
create a new instance of the module type
and then I'll copy everything over it is
possible to do module level properties
in Python it's only about seven or eight
lines of code and what you're doing is
you're just understanding that module a
is an attribute lookup than any other
actor beaut lookup so that
key to making this work is just be able
to create your own module type let's
look at mutable default arguments this
code is executed top to bottom left to
right this line is executed this line
these two lines are parsed turned into
byte code and then stored in that code
object
so when line three is executed you would
create one list that gets reused every
time that's why this uses the same list
as this as this because that list is
only ever constructed once however when
I do this notice the list is constructed
as part of the execution of the function
so a new list is used every time when I
wrap this in a wrapped function notice
that this function is Reax acute 'add
every time the outer function is
executed so a new list is used every
single time when I try this with the
decorator syntax it doesn't work because
this line is executed once and it
doesn't matter what happened in this
decorator what matters is how many times
do i execute that top line of that
function which is only once
so this retains the bad behavior when I
stick this into a class the body of a
class is executed and put into a
namespace and then stored on the type
and so this gets executed once under
this namespace so the bad behavior is
retained same in this case let's take a
look at our scope problem z is a local z
as a global variable the Python
interpreter does not know where the Z in
this line comes from so it will assume
by default its global variable in a
module scope the locals and Global's are
the same object so this just works I
don't have to execute it here well that
doesn't do anything interesting here
Python sees an X variable it tries to
figure out where did that X variable
come from it can't see an x equals
anywhere here it can't arbitrarily go
into this code because you could make
this really you can make this
arbitrarily complicated right so Python
won't execute anything to figure out
I'll just look for a line that says x
equals or import X or import from Y
import X
there's only a set number of ways you
can bring a variable into scope or from
Y import Z as X or with something as X
or for X in something or accept if
you're an exception something as X it's
only a couple ways you can create an X
variable so to look for all of those it
won't find them it'll say oh well X must
be a global variable and this change the
locals won't be picked up when we
disassemble this we'll see that Python
assumed statically that this was a
global variable so the only thing the
Python compiler does that's interesting
at all it figures out where variables
come from in order to optimize variable
lookup they'll assume statically X is a
global variable and the change to locals
won't have effect here we see something
interesting when we look at that load
fast it didn't read from Global's so I
didn't read from locals and read from a
special array that's attached to the
frame object so this will have no effect
whatsoever here this works because
python cannot find where that X variable
comes from it assumes it's a global
variable and the reason it assumes
things are global variables is you could
have something like this and so by
default that's the last place you look
it's probably a global variable and if
you can't find the execution it was
probably an import star operation that
occurred somewhere that made everything
very hard to find so this works
Python assumes it's a global variable
and it actually looks in the global
dictionary and finds the value you want
here
Python knows this is a closure variable
because it can see it up here so this
won't work and this won't work because
that's not where pythons looking for the
variable finally in this example what
Python thinks this line says is that
Python thinks there's a local variable X
because you set x equals when it tries
to evaluate this line it tries to use
the local variable X that it knows
exists in this scope but it doesn't
exist until this line is completed
execution so Python won't even look up
to the closure to find it so the
solution for this is non-local X I told
you there are two there's actually three
non-executable Python statements they
are global non-local and of course pass
now pass isn't very interesting but
global and non-local are interesting all
they do is they tell the Python
interpreter where the variable came from
there's no corresponding byte code for
local for non local or global they're
just hints to the Python interpreter
that hey you can't find this variable
I'll tell you where it comes from it
comes from the dereference scope it
comes from the global scope and it just
guides the Python interpreter into
emitting the correct byte by coding and
that's the end of our questions so you
can see what the very simple model for
how Python works if you don't overthink
it
if you don't reach for the complexity of
a language like C++ or Java in there in
terms of their execution models you can
end up answering every single one of
these questions many of which seems very
perplexing at the beginning of this talk
which is a very simple mental model
Python interpreter only executes modules
the first time they are imported it
executes them from top to bottom left to
right the DEF statement or the class
statement is part of the executable code
the body of that function is just turned
into a code object the DEF for the class
statement or executable code they
correspond to used to be a make class
and make function but in Python 3 it's
now make function to build a function
and then to make functions to build a
class
don't ask there's a simplification that
we can talk about later and that's it
and every one of these questions which
might lead you on Stack Overflow for
hours and hours to pick up wrong or
incorrect or overly complex mental
models are unnecessary with one simple
mental model every one of these
questions can be answered immediately
and with sufficient nuance to really
understand what your Python code does so
that was top-down left-to-right
you
you